il n'a pas pu s'en empêcher à près de 80
ans michel allard a tenté quelques tirs
au panier
cet ancien joueur et dirigeant du club
de trappes la verrière est venu voir
jouer les seniors de nationale 3
l'occasion d'évoquer ses souvenirs
d'entraîneur quelques photos peut-être
que vous êtes dessus nasale la cause
rappelle qu'à regret qu'elle ouvrait sa
carrière ses racines il ya la caméra
rachid
il nous a trahis at il ajouté depuis son
avc en 2009 il n'avait plus revu un
match 2 le fc trappes un manque pour ce
passionné qui a marqué ses premiers
paniers à l'âge de 8 ans ça va sacrer
vrai que j'ai rendu pour le bac est pour
moi c'était ma famille comme
ma faim c'était ma famille à ma quand la
rencontre débute michel allard n'hésite
pas à commenter les actions son passé
d'entraîneur ressurgi sur le bord du
terrain
tu es plus clémente c'est trop longtemps
à les autres rencontres les roses ou
encore là sur le banc de touche à ses
côtés l'association manic oise
éducatives et culturelles a organisé
cette sortie et surtout sa petite fille
alexandre ça me fait très plaisir
surtout que ces voix là c'est quelque
chose qui voulait faire de 15
un moment donc moi ça ne me plaisait de
l'accompagner ce soir pour ce beau match
en fait quand j'étais plus jeune je
l'accompagnais à ces matchs de basket
je regardais donc j'ai toujours baigné
dedans accompagner les seniors dans
leurs rêves et leurs envies par
l'intermédiaire de deux jeunes adultes
de l'adolescent de la commune de magny
ou autres lors de cette rencontre trappe
s'inclinent finalement sur le score de
64 à 88 face au havre et le passionné
dresse son bilan par rapport à cette
défaite
cette année ils savent pas fin qu'aux
tracas et chaque remplacé en gueule il
est resté le même personnage à savoir à
très impliqué pas toujours modérée dans
ses appréciations bas faudra qu'ils
reviennent la prochaine fois et en fera
mieux en france lyon gagnera au moins et
michel allard compte revenir pour une
prochaine rencontre de le fc trappes
avec l'espoir d'assister cette fois ci à
une victoire de son club